manifestation
ce qui m'a choqué depuis plusieurs jours
c'est l'instrumentalisation politique et
ça en fait partie
n'ajoutons pas l'indignité à l'atrocité
ce qui s'est passé vendredi soir je
pense nous a tous profondément
bouleversé et je souhaite que
collectivement on soit en soutien des
parents des parents de la petite Lola
qu'on laisse la justice travailler je
voudrais aussi saluer la diligence des
forces de police qui est en quelques
heures on retrouvait la meurtrière
présumée mais voilà je pense que on est
dans un temps où il faut laisser faire
la journée vous avez dit une ajoutons
pas l'indignité à la trocité ce qu'on a
vu là c'est indigne ce qu'on a vu depuis
lundi dernier notamment mardi dernier
lors des questions d'actualité et
d'ailleurs le rassemblement du
rassemblement national a été fait pour
ce ne pas être avec la récupération de
d'en faire au chaud globalement pas
d'instrumentalisation sur cette
abominable à faire et soyons respectons
ce que les parents de la petite Lola ont
souhaité c'est-à-dire à leur côté sans
instrumentalisation moi j'ai été toute
la journée en hémicycle donc j'ai
assisté j'ai assisté à des scènes encore
une fois
assez étonnante de la part de gens qui
disent défendre le Parlement puisqu'on a
débattu d'une motion de rejet donc ne
pas discuter de votre collègue Jérôme
Guedj a déposé une motion de rejet pour
qu'on ne discute pas du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
puis après on a discuté de des comptes
administratifs l'équivalent des comptes
administratifs de 2021 c'est-à-dire
prendre acte de ce qui s'est passé en
2021 les oppositions ce sont toutes
coalisées pour voter contre ce qui ne
sert strictement à rien il y avait pas
de volonté d'avancer sur ce texte et moi
je le regrette profondément parce que le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale c'est une augmentation
majeure pour l'hôpital c'est ce sont des
choses jamais vues sur la question de la
prévention on dit souvent qu'on est très
très bon sur les soins en France on est
mauvais sur la prévention là c'est enfin
un
élan qui est donné sur la prévention
c'est aussi des efforts extrêmement
significatifs sur l'accès aux soins et
moi je regrette évidemment que qu'on
n'est pas qu'on n'est pas ce débat il a
eu lieu en commission c'était de très
bons niveaux les oppositions ont décidé
aujourd'hui qu'elles ne voulait pas
l'avoir en hémicycle donc acte il faut
qu'on avance